[Music]
i
i'm very flustered that you're here what
because i'm flustered to be here i love
you starting out this way like
but you instantly put me at ease really
i'm like
honestly have never felt this
comfortable around
you well on cameras is where we both
feel the most comfortable
that's true but before this downstairs
and then you let me come in your room
and you're like changing your peeing
with the door open but even before that
the second you open the door
to your mansion you were just you just
go
do you need anything what did you say to
me you said something that i was like
mom i took out my people
what do you need
i was sitting on the toilet like because
i go i gotta go to the bathroom i was
sitting in there
in your perfect bathroom that's like
dimly lit and i just wanted to like
camp out in there it's better than my
like anything i've
ever any room i've ever owned or rented
is that bathroom that's my panic room
but okay it should it's
incredible in there i lit and you had
towels instead of
like paper towels and there was i just
like don't know what to do with a towel
like a personal towel
did you steal it i just i thought about
it because i was like there's nowhere to
put this thing
so i just kind of like tossed it gently
on the counter and hoping that it gets
blamed on someone else someone they're
going to reuse it in the time of coven
but i should have disposable napkins no
that was
you're that was the right thing to do
but i was sitting there and i was just
it just resonated in my head like
but what do you need what do you what do
you need it was just so loving you're
i get that energy from you now and
you're like i need to leave
if i'm to be honest i want to stay
i really am digging your vibe like
what's going
every time i run into you i mean i was
talking about you on stage for a while
because i was talking about that damn
book you turned me on to
i want to get into that but i want to
get so much but i want to start i always
start the podcast asking the guest
i don't get to chime in at all i don't
do intros asking the guests
if we're friends and what our
relationship is oh my god because a lot
of times we're dysmorphic about how our
relationships are with people yeah
you get to describe it well okay
i would yes i would call you a friend
would i go on to be like
we hang out all the time and talk all
the time
definitely not like but would i be down
definitely yes and it like so much so
now i'm like so
like into everything that's happening in
this house
and like your vibe i'm just like digging
you but um
yeah we're friends yeah i would say for
like i would say my friend whitney
cummings if i was to talk about you but
i wouldn't
it sounds like a name drop so i would go
on to elaborate like but we're not
best friends and i don't want i'm not
like tooting my own horn but yes i do
text her and like
i could call you now i know and i've
called you once in covid
i could call you about anything and like
get just a really
nice kind what do you need response
so yes yes you did freeze as if you've
never been asked to that before i don't
think i have you do look did look
confounded it was so
nice it's like i'm gonna steal that for
when i have like a
a mansion of my own when i greet us what
do you need it's actually a good thing
to ask
a man when he's upset or when someone's
upset
at you not just a man just what do you
need
yes how can i help you again it just
washed over me in a way that i will
think it will
it's resonating it feels good she just
started hysterically crying
but we were we were we were friends i
was thinking about it today
i do have a resentment because i
believe we should be better friends
i love that so much i
really appreciate i've i that's all i
want i've only given you distance
because i feel like
i don't want to you have too many
friends you you work too hard
not anymore they all just got cancelled
i have a big
big opening in the
a stable of availability and my
favorites on my phone
well um i'm taking applications
i'll put mine in i really i feel like
whenever i see you i feel very connected
to you and i feel very
close to you and i get suspicious
because
i am a codependent entrencher and i do
get too close to people too fast
sometimes
and i trauma bond with people and so i
think i
i've always i've always just been really
um i've over
thought you a lot like when i see you
i'm always like why are we better
friends and should i just
we should be why are we friends like i
just i i think about it
and then i'm always like oh well she
lives in new york and like yeah you know
that's that oh mike well i'm really
flattered that
you that feels so that's so nice and so
unexpected because
i felt the same about you but just felt
like
you were like i i don't know because we
were
we i remember i was moving to l.a in
2006 right out of college i
knew no one right and i came across a
clip of yours had you done kimmel at
that point
2006 like your first appearance like
what was your first appearance that you
might have had on your myspace i'm a
bouquet
i'm obsessed when people try to give you
a compliment and they over compliment
you and then you have to admit what it
was
and it ends up being embarrassing so
she's like dude
kimmel and i'm like no it was last call
with carson daly
did you do that that was it that was
sabotage
um that was it that was a big deal
that was a big deal and i remember
seeing your clip and just and that's how
i kind of moved to la and found friends
was i just
reached out to different comedians and
was like i'm moving to town can we be
friends oh nice
and you were you got back to me and were
like of course and then i
followed you around town and you took me
to all the open mics introduced me to
everyone you were so nice
and i tried to keep up with you when i
couldn't like you were
just do you remember how hard i mean you
still work that hard but just in a
different way
and it was insane i learned a lot from
you really yeah you
running around that you were hitting
like and their open bikes were hard to
come by back
yeah we remember there was one that was
like a coffee shop oh you had to go to a
website i believe it was called
chucklemonkey
yes.com which is a problematic
candle uh and then you would go it might
be happening it might not they'd have to
have enough people you would like drive
to van nuys drive they wanted some
pulverdup like
you would wait for two hours they'd pull
your name out of a thing you'd get up
and do sportsman's life
that was my shit that's my shit yeah you
you just would show up you were so cool
and you were like kind of fresh on the
scene
too i mean yeah but you were you just
had no you you were you were so nice and
you like took me under your wing and i
remember we would write
together but you were just in another
league in terms of like i know what i'm
doing i know what i want
and i my addiction was just way more
intense
and then you just you took off and i
remember
i was moving back to st louis because i
ran out of money and was like
things weren't going the way i wanted
them to and i was just and i remember
being back in st louis and you were
i we talked on the phone about something
you were giving me advice about
something great and you were talking
about doing the roast and i was like
she's gone
she's gone like she's it's just you were
in another
level so quickly i mean you and
you've only continued um i remember
i have so many so many weird feelings
about that time because it was so clear
that i was an unrecovered addict
it workaholism right and my fear of
failure was so intense i i almost feel
like i was unconscious like i've blacked
out so much of that like people tell me
they're like you used to run around in a
backpack and i'm like
i don't know i literally was unconscious
and
i have so much insecurity about that
time and so much embarrassment
in a weird way like shame because i
people call me ambitious and that my
brain
always takes that as a rejection number
one
you're not really talented you're not
just working really hard you just
weren't which is fine too
okay sure that is fine not the case with
you but i have the same i
know exactly what you're saying and i
want to just have a caveat and say
no that's you have both and that's what
makes you
doesn't it weird you out when someone
calls you ambitious oh yeah when they go
you work so
or you deserve that you really deserve
that you work really hard it's like
so you just think the only difference
between me and you not
okay is that i just i i had more time
and i i don't have a family or whatever
or what it is
like they're also saying it's not
effortless for you like it couldn't be
you know what i mean well i've wanted to
be as effortless yeah it's just like so
i don't know and maybe it's just because
i'm
it's like ooky when someone says you're
so ambitious it's like you look tired
there's something um dismissive about it
and there's something like
uh uh pathological about it like you're
ambitious like you need this
you have a hole to fill or something it
is
it's and it's weird because you i
remember
uh i think even people that you really
adore and like and respect can trigger
you sometimes and show you
invisible wounds when you were working
on your new special which is fucking
brilliant thanks girl uh banging on
netflix i'm sure you've seen it watch it
again
uh you were like working around the
clubs and you were doing like i would
see your name on like a couple lineups
and i was like
what the fuck is she doing i was like
okay like all right we're doing this
and i remember being like i need to work
harder and then i was like what's that
like i saw your work ethic and it held
up some like insecurity for me
i i feel that way all the time six
months ago
yeah yeah but we can look we can but i'm
still like that i'm
in that man like i i it's funny to hear
that someone
like you would have looked at me and
felt that way because i was
trying to keep up with you we're all as
much as we say that
we don't want to compete with other
women this it's so hard to feel
like you shouldn't and that and to tell
yourself that it's not a competition but
also
we should like in a way that we have to
but there's a way to do it where i like
to go i remember when anthony jeselnik
was on was like
i like aspirational competition going
she did it i can do it too
oh yeah you know what i mean in a way
that we can be not competitive as a
scarcity complex like if she gets it i
don't get it it's not that it's oh my
god there's room for all of us
yes if she but like to me i always root
for women to be successful because i'm
like
please i want your show to go eight
seasons because that means people go see
women can
syndicate yeah it's good for all of us
yes when women win and i think it's so
anathema of the way we're programmed
i i completely i yeah i don't think it's
about like oh there's one spot and she's
gonna get it and i'm not it's like
she will be so much better that it'll
make me like look so terrible that i
won't ever work again because i have to
keep up with being that good
yeah and i think that's where i get the
competitive nature but
even you're saying like i get jealous of
when people are like running themselves
ragged like yeah and
don't look good and have it slept like i
get jealous of the things when people
are really terrible to themselves it's
clear that they're
not well yeah but i get jealous of that
i'm like why can't i
be that addicted to it and and yeah
but but the goal is to feel good so i
don't really know what the hell to do i
mean like
that's what i was just saying to you
about getting back into stand up and i'm
like i don't
really want to go back out there right
now yeah i don't feel like working the
clubs
but i'm so scared to not stay
on the level with everyone else because
the stand-up it's like the gym
you gotta fucking work that do it a lot
you can't just do one show here and
there
at least i can't i also though think you
have
carved a niche god that's so boomer of
me to say
like what you do has gotten so specific
and so granular in terms of analyzing
your psyche and looking at yourself that
a lot of the work
that you are doing moving forward can be
done without being in front of an
audience
i do sometimes think we go in front of
an audience so much
that we i'd like to take years off
between i took a year off after my
third special before my fourth special
really so that i was like not just doing
a bad impression of myself
yeah i had to grow i had to i felt that
in your special like oh nice feel like i
felt
just and and talk about intimidation
with specials like
yours coming out like right before i
think it was before i was going to tame
me in or
right before mine came out and just
watching it and being like i remember
being like i need to
step it up and being feeling inspired i
would say i hope that's a good thing
you know what i mean not not threatened
ins and truly i'm saying that like
uh i want to be doing stuff that makes
people think the way this is changing
the way that i do you do that with me
like i see the work that you're doing
and like i watch my shit i'm like
damn like she is fucking fearless in a
way that i thought i was fearless
like she is because i think comedy is
becoming
unless you're going to be
constitutionally honest with yourself
and fucking vulnerable you are only as
sick as your secrets and you could do
not get to have secrets anymore
no you don't and we will find out about
those secrets and you will not i don't
and i as a consumer don't want to watch
stand-up comedians who aren't being
fully honest so when i find out that
someone is a monster behind closed doors
even if they're my favorite comic which
they have been before i'm not interested
afterwards because i'm like you were
lying
you're fucking phony yeah the one place
you're allowed to talk about how big of
a scumbag you are
yes you fucking just lie be honest
up there this is what we do we say i lie
and i cheat and i'm jealous and i'm
disgusting
yeah i'm an addict and you still fucking
lie
that's that's it if you had just said
i'm a fucking scumbag we would have been
like good for them
i know i know you fucking cheated us and
you tried to hoodwink us and that's the
kind of shit i don't play that shit i
know
and and and i think that's what peop
people want that uh
like honesty now like it's just all that
do you ever get scared are you ever like
oh god why did i say that
or like i wish i hadn't shared that yes
because sometimes
like on my podcast recently like i've
just been really i've been like
depressed and quarantined like up and
down
and like having some low lows that i'm
like embarrassed about where i say
things on the phone with my friends that
like
concern them like my dad will call me if
i go on a run and be like
are you are you okay and i'm like oh you
think i jumped off a bridge like
saying stuff like that that no please
please laugh if you don't
i'm only as sick as my secrets whitney
you said it out loud we released some
shame
yes but i've been saying some dark shit
just yeah and i think i say that stuff
when i'm really depressed because
i want a reaction i want someone to be
worried i want somebody to
laugh say what do you need yeah um
you know i grew up i got attention
pretty much only when i was sick
and it took me a really long time to
stop victimizing myself or pretending i
was sick
in order to get attention and love i
thought i had to be weak or broken to be
loved i admitted this to
a friend of ours uh taylor tomlinson
who's downstairs right now she was
talking about her night terror she has
night terrors
and i assume that's not a secret but if
it is i'll ask i promise
yeah uh and she was like i have night
terrors and then my boyfriend will wake
me up and i just blurted out i said
when i was in my 20s i pretended to have
night terrors so men would fall in love
with me
oh my god oh my god
wait see who would like wake up gently
in the middle of the night to go pee or
something
and then you would get ready and go like
how am i really going to sell this and
like i would just be like lying like
this just so they'd hold you
like it's okay it's
it was proposed to uh by many men in my
twenties um
uh they are now in rehab doing great uh
i see i thought that no one wanted a
healed whole healthy functioning person
yes yes i thought i had to be sick for
anyone to care or pay attention to me oh
wow
i don't know if i have that as much as
that i i
hmm it's like if they love
fucking love at all costs but so scared
that if
you get it they'll it'll go away and you
need to manipulate to get it like my
thing is like
being not being like when i'm with a
boyfriend i'm fine
i am perfect there's no alarm like i
would never really share
like deep depressing thoughts with like
a boyfriend type person because i don't
want them to be like i can't deal with
this
like i i keep that stuff kind of hidden
like everything's fine
be in a whole relationship and never
once complain to him
about his behavior about anything
because i'm so scared that if i say
anything critical about or like voice of
concern
and he'll go well you're ugly and
i you don't deserve to be with me anyway
and so
are you having any complaint i'm gonna
leave because i don't need this i'm not
gonna change
like my biggest fear is them being like
you're well
spewing out all the things that they've
been hiding and be like well you're this
and this and this
and then be like oh i can't take it and
you mean either they'll get overwhelmed
by the fact that you have needs
or they'll use it as ammo against you
later they'll
they'll just tell me in the like set so
if i'm like i don't like the way you
talk to me well
i don't like this and this and this and
this and this is and i then i'm just
like
you see all these things and i won't be
able to recover or
hey i don't like this about you i'll say
and then they go well
that's the way i'm so bi and then i'm
like i guess i have to go yeah
yeah because i've had to do that before
where you break up you have to break up
with someone because you're like i need
this the one time i asked for something
he couldn't give it and i was like
i guess i have to break up with you i
just thought that was going to be an
easy thing yeah
yeah that was like a rhetorical thing
you were supposed to have you seen
movies
yeah you know how this is actually
supposed to work uh you're supposed to
come to my job and apologize and get me
back
yep and i'm just scared of yeah
so i mean i've relationships are just
like
i'm just doing the work on myself right
now i mean that's my deal because
a little late it's not a little late no
no no no no no
so many years once you really start the
work on yourself to be like
open to others loving you and i'm like
i'm 36 i should have fucking
might know this few years
i believe uh firmly at this point that
we only attract people who are as
healthy as we are
and my goal now is to get okay yes
healthy enough to attract the person i
want
because you're not healthy the person
you want's not gonna be interested in
you
only sick people are to be interested in
sick people so if i just get my shit
together and we kind of
become the person i remember one time a
therapist said to me
when i was in my 20s and i was cheating
and i was manipulating and lying and
codependent and controlling and
mothering and micromanaging and
martyring and the whole thing
i can't wait to hang out with you and
hear each one of those like
the stories behind each one of those uh
glamping she said something that was
you know how sometimes whether you're
just ready to hear you're primed to hear
you hear the right thing at the right
time it just hits you exactly how
you need to hear it it's so simple she
just went would you want to date you
oh and i was like fuck no like no it'd
be a nightmare that'd be exhausting
yeah you know because what i was
realizing is that i would shapeshift
into what i thought the other person
wanted which to me is like a benevolent
act of charity like i'm turning into
this person you want it i'm cheering for
the team you like and i'm
converting to the religion that you like
and i'm doing this and i'm meditating
and i'm doing
and but it's lying and they resent you
and they resent you for eventually the
jig's going to be up and you're going to
have to take the wig off or whatever
you know and then they're like wait a
second who's who's this person and then
you resent them because you were acting
the whole time
yep and then they now have to meet this
new person and also it's
it you lose respect for them i have this
theory that when you lie to someone you
lose respect for them because they
bought it
yes i fucking bought that i fooled you
yeah yeah yeah you pathetic that you
didn't even see through this fucking act
it's toxic on every level but i truly
didn't know any other way than like you
trick a guy into loving you
you just you have to manipulate and be
someone that you're not
and there's no other way and i still
struggle with it like of
just tr because i still compare myself
so much to
to looks wise and career-wise like
there's so much comparison going on
there's so much um i'm not good enough
uh stuff even though every year it gets
better
because you have to let this stuff go
but like i don't know i was on the way
here
and i just taped kimmel and
uh and i posted a picture of myself
which i haven't posted like a glam shot
in months now right because of
quarantine and it's like a shot where
i'm just like
i look pretty you know what i'm done by
the way i'm going to say something
that's
i'm a sexist pig like you look
incredible we all talk about it
it's like a topic of conversation that's
really gossip about how hot you are all
the time wow
comes up a lot i'm a predator um i said
it
likewise i don't know if you i don't
know how you wouldn't know that about
you but it's
literally like been a lot like
you're so pretty some girls don't like
you
it seems to you thank you i don't like
you sometimes
because of instagram i have to there's
been times where i've almost had to mute
you because you're so pretty
i will admit it i've muted you i will
just say it i've muted you because
you're too pretty
it's not been anything else it's like
your boobs look too good
you're having too much fun you're too
pretty and i've had to put you on mute
and then i forget because something
something will come up and i am like why
hasn't she posted about that yet
she's doing that thing and it's like oh
you were too insecure to
hear about your friend doing a cool
thing so
done it well my kids are fake but thank
you
they are yes i didn't know that about
you although i'm sure i've talked about
it was
with other female comics and speculated
for hours on end i will dish
literally fucking everything my tits are
completely fake they're so good though
yeah
aren't you happy with them i'm super
happy with them i didn't get them
until i was 33
i want to say i got my that's pretty
late pretty late you know
cause you were already cranking by then
i mean were you worried that people were
going to be like
pay for them i had to get money first
but
they don't really do layaway with tits
out here but the first round of bursting
pens i got
the first one i got because i had such
bad eating disorders
that i thought okay if i just get bigger
boobs
i'll feel better about my body because i
was trying to match my body to my boob
size but then it was this weird
whack-a-mole because my boobs wouldn't
grow because i
was so uh malnourished when i was a
teenager so they like grew in these
weird sizes and
my mom had boobs and uh my aunts had
boobs like genetically i'm supposed to
have boobs and it been
but my eating disorder thwarted them i
was so ashamed to get about getting
breast implants i literally went online
and googled like breston plant los
angeles
went to a guy who worked out of his hat
this shoe out of his
house he did the surgery by the airport
it was like four thousand dollars not
see they're not it was not
it was and he cut through a muscle and
like totally fucked him up
so i but i was so embarrassed to ask
like who's the good person like oh right
you did it all on youtube i didn't tell
you
i understand i was shooting a movie
and then people still like did that
movie ever come out no like i
created this weird elaborate lie and um
and it was crazy because you can't lift
things for like four weeks and i was
like
a t-rex like trying to lift things like
it was like kind of a rock bottom in my
co-dependence and fear of embarrassment
or
my body stuff and then i got them fixed
i want to say
like three years ago by someone that
knows how to do it who has a license oh
that's great
yes when you're getting like surgery by
the airport like
betterhelp.com as phone a friend go to a
12-step meeting
i um i love hearing about that because
yeah i mean i i'm i've looked into all
of that
stuff and i'm still like not putting it
off the table to get
work done but it i the stuff that i have
had done the injections in my face
those intense lasers where you your body
seriously thinks it's being burned alive
so you they have to hold you down
because you'll
try to escape i had a laser where they
they were like strapped you down because
they're like well your body thinks it's
on fire
so it's going to want to like the
instincts are going to want to run into
a lake
a nearby body an aqueduct your fight or
flight responses
you're getting physically violent and
stronger frankly yeah this is going to
be
like so they had to strap you down
because it burned my face so much
to look better and i remember doing that
and being like
wow i just like that such abuse to
yourself that's so
mean to you to your body to put it into
that kind of shock where it thinks it's
dying so that i can look uh it didn't
even like i didn't even
notice or care like those answers are
not ideal but it i just the beauty shit
like so i was on the way over here and
i'm like
by the way if i may we also look at
ourselves way more than we should and if
this is all
getting worse like i don't do zoom
meetings or zoom podcasts anymore thank
you so much for coming in person
and i've been wanting to have you guys
for so long i can't look at the zooms
because you're just looking at yourself
i know i can't stare at myself all day
i'm already too dysmorphic
you know they say that if you were to
run into yourself on the street you
wouldn't even recognize yourself that's
how dysmorphic we are
oh my god and i believe that
because i have sometimes seen a
reflection of myself
in like a bank window or whatever yeah
and i go oh my gosh she's so cute and
then i realize it's me and i go yeah
on a dime that flips like that
and let me ask you a crazy question is
part of the reason that we're so
self-critical
is and does any of this in our brains
is part of what makes us funny are we
allowed to like ourselves and be funny
like can we give ourselves permission to
be able to be incredibly self-critical
self-deprecating
yes i think we can yes because we've
been on the other side
so we know and it's it's right there if
we want to go back to it what if we were
just to view ourselves the way other
people view us like that's
that's that's kind of my thing with you
it's just like you don't get to weigh in
on yourself
you just outsource your um self-esteem
and worth to like me just see yourself
the way i see you and like you'll be
good
yeah the way everybody else sees you
well it's tough
i mean i should i should be biased we
can't weigh in on ourselves because we
know too much about the gross shit we've
done in the past
yeah you know and and you're you're
absolutely right there are select
friends that i do reach out to when i
need a boost to self-esteem to like see
myself clearly because i know that
i trust their judgment they have good
taste in people and
art and so like when they tell me i'm
funny or when they tell me i'm beautiful
which the latter i like struggle with
because there will be a time where i'm
not fuckable like i don't like if i get
old enough
hopefully no one wants to fuck me i
don't want to be
fuckable and very vulnerable and old and
like brittle
you're supposed to be grosser when you
get older so like men don't want to rape
you all the time
because they could because you're a weak
children and old people not fuckable
because they're weak that's my theory
right
so i'm not saying old older women aren't
fuckable but you lose that it is a die
you are a dying battery of fuckability
yeah i do believe which is okay
i have to be okay with that um and i am
getting better with it because when i
was on the way over here
i'm like posted this beautiful picture
of me which is like
filter full hair and makeup like the
best any one the best i can best i can
do
frankly my peek which i don't like i
don't like that we get to
look the best we can look i i like to
like have an extra gear where i'm like
well
i don't really know but i do nothing in
my back pocket yeah you know this is it
nope we've peaked so
like you just look in the mirror and
you're like there's nothing else that
can be done and it's great
and then people pilot i mean the
comments fire fire fire emoji
stunning bringing the look like all the
like it it felt like
this isn't me and finally i'm getting
all the things that i've ever wanted
people to say to me and like be
overwhelming about like my
my dancing partner on dancing with the
stars is like giving me like
fire emojis and i'm just like that's all
i've ever wanted from you club and it's
like
but that is not me that is not and it
just
feels safe what is it is it like an
imposter syndrome
or is it like one too many a million not
enough i got the thing i wanted and
that's not working
it's that what i have a mask on right
now dressed up in this outfit we should
be wearing masks but
i know i don't have in the photo i don't
have a mask we're actually not which has
there's six layers there but not one of
them is a
cute tie-dye cotton uh facial mask but
i just feel like i was just my friend
drove me here i was just like this makes
me depressed because
i'm getting all the things i want but i
don't that's not me and if that's
what people want and are gonna give
approval to i can't keep that
up it's exhausting it will not be kept
this is it's sustainable this is
ephemeral
it's um i have it it's called anadonia
which is when you
can't enjoy the moment because you're
grieving the moment's going to be over
soon
which is a big like for me i don't like
going on fancy trips or going to fancy
places you have to say goodbye
as soon as i go see like a beautiful
sunset i start to panic so i'm like this
is gonna be over soon this will be over
soon like you're not doing a good enough
job enjoying this like you need to be in
the moment you need to take a picture
like i completely
suffocate myself with these like
perfectionist expectations of how i need
to be enjoying that moment
and how i need to be receiving i can't
stand when people give me gifts
i i don't because i'm like i'm not going
to receive this well i'm not fight
i i'm going to i love this but i feel
like
you're gonna think i'm lying because if
i don't always feel phony you gave me a
goddamn gift bag that i'm so excited
about and i like
i got stressed out i was just like i
want to look at everything in here and i
want to thank her for everything in here
but
is it the time is now is it should i do
it later as i gave it to you just walked
away
you realized i didn't want to put
pressure i didn't want to put pressure
on you because i was like oh my god
so excited about this bag and i can't
wait to dig into it but i was like
is that weird to do now or like uh thank
you so much by the way i think receiving
love and attention it is so
interesting when you gravitate towards a
job where you're saying
i'm going to talk for an hour you're all
going to shut up
to receive yeah and if you speak you
will be removed by security
i know i must have some confidence
somewhere
but then as soon as this uh involuntary
slap
of laughter from you guys is gone i i
get very lost you know it's like
we say i'm program is i'm a piece of
shit in the center of the universe
yes that laughter like i have gotten so
bad as like i can't even let the
laughter die down like i
talk it's one of my like flaws as a
comic when i watch myself i'm like
just let the left let them laugh do you
need to like pile on but i'm so scared
i before you think i'm not funny again
here's me being funny again
and it's like just take a fucking breath
you know let me know
if you're listening to this you've been
hearing me talking to nikki glazer we're
talking about
health we're sh we're talking about how
good we both look
and i fully attribute if i look healthy
at all
to taking ritual vitamins and i'm not
joking even though that was an
incredibly good segue
it really was a good segue but it's also
true it is true such a true segue you
take them like they're candy
ritual is this incredible vitamin
that has everything that you need
and it comes to your door you've heard
me talk about it i'm paraphrasing
but that was close it was pretty i
actually buy this product so i'm not
reading the copy you know me i like to
wing it
ritual is the obsessively researched
vitamin for women
rituals essential and you're both those
things a woman and obsessive
as an obsessive woman this is the
right-wing thing for me it should take
if a virgo takes up this pill you should
too
you know we've researched it they have
the nutrients most of us don't get
enough of from
food all in their clean absorbable forms
no shady additives no ingredients that
can do more harm
to your body then good two easy to take
capsules provide
nine nutrients you need to support a
strong foundation for your health and
what is more important than your health
right now
the best thing is they have this this
capsule that
is you don't get sick you can take it on
an empty stomach you don't get nauseous
and there's a little mint tab in every
bottle to keep it fresh so you don't get
that
fishy aftertaste with the other omega-3
pills where it's all
gross sugar-free non-gmo gluten-free
allergen free and all of their
ingredients are right there on the
bottle no shady sketchy secret
ingredients
ritual also is delivered because if you
know anything about me you know that i
cannot keep track of anything and also
can't leave your house
also there's that uh ritual delivers
to your door the worst is when you get
on a new sort of regimen of like taking
care of yourself like you're taking
a new vitamin and then you like run out
and then you want to give up
you think i'm like i'm not going to the
store yeah you're like okay my health
isn't worth
you know getting in my car and driving
five minutes but just having it
delivered to your door you don't have to
think about it because self-care it's
hard for me
to take care of myself unless it just
shows up in my door and i'm like oh it's
here i'll take it
you know that's why i mean anything that
should look at your door you take it
yeah i just i just
i'll take a vitamin as long as i don't
have to like think about having to take
a bite they just make it very easy for
you to do
better health does not happen overnight
right now ritual is offering my
listeners 10
off during your first three months fill
in the gaps in your diet with essential
for women a small step that helps
support a healthy foundation
for that body
visit rachel.com whitney to start your
ritual today
that's ten percent off during your first
three months at ritual.com
whitney we made it
me undies i'm not even reading the copy
you don't have to tell us every time
anymore i'm just i know i just want you
guys to know i
i listen to podcasts i've been listening
to a lot of podcasts and i'm hearing a
lot of
hucksters that's our next merch i'm not
reading the copy i don't read the copy
i listen to these people just like
zombies
drudging through the copy pretending
they use a product that's sponsoring
their podcast
not us we showed you that we we love the
pr
dude me undies this is my favorite pair
of underwear if you're listening and not
watching i'm holding up a thong that is
maroon
with a little purple band and it is so
comfortable
and if you're watching feel my underwear
if you're watching and not listening
it's weird and it's these are the
softest underwear i don't know what i'm
supposed to be reading about okay
though look me undies is serious about
softness like so
serious they scoured the world for the
softest fabric known to man
it really is they're my favorite
underwear it's almost like um
velvet remember crushed velvet no it
feels like i do remember questions it
feels like you know what it feels like
it feels like
tell us quick what does it feel like it
feels like um
what is this voice those voices and you
know what it feels like
i've never felt anything in my whole
life like it sir i just oh it just feels
so
warm and cozy and nice really and i hope
you can have like what is that
uh will you transport it back in time
what the hell are you doing oh god i
don't know
mama and you were there and you were
there you were there too
it's just like it it almost feels like
yummy salt water like you know when you
feel
what you know when you're like in a salt
water pool and it's like
creamy it's like wearing a
water bed guys it's crazy um you know
what
here's the thing these underwear are
really soft and comfortable
stop we're going to lose the sponsor
they're the most comfortable under where
they really are
long before i was part of this i was
subscribed to the underwear
and i've worn them forever i mean
they're great waiting to subscribe to
them we get them every month
when you run around it doesn't they
don't move the biggest problem for me
with underwear is you sweat
and move and number one over time the
elasticity
breaks and it'll just start being baggy
and you'll get like a front wedgie
um these do not do that and when you
work out it doesn't they don't move
around
and when you watch them they go right
back to their original shape they're
really
so much i'm rubbing my face you can
literally you just go online you can
sign up for the membership they get sent
right to your door like everything else
oh you get you get them uh once a month
right yep you can pick if you want fun
pair if you want the classic colors like
we have a little llamas on them
they have all kinds of stuff and right
now meandes has a great offer offer for
the listeners for
any first time purchaser you get 15 off
and free shipping 15
off that's crazy yeah this is a
no-brainer especially because they have
a hundred percent satisfaction guarantee
to get your 15
off your first pair free shipping and a
hundred percent
satisfaction guaranteed go to
meundies.com
whitney that's meundies.com whitney
can i say something to you this might
not go well
i cannot wait this is so exciting every
time you've dropped like one of these so
far i've been like
so flattered so this could go a lot of
pressure
i disagree i feel like when i see you
and maybe you just feel that
i know what it's like to feel like
you're rushing when you're not
yeah when i see you i'm like she's so
composed and she's moving
so elegant i don't feel i whatever
you're doing just keep doing okay
if it's uncomfortable for you then then
fine yeah you're not supposed to have
fun up there
i know it's not for you
i love it we're like our job is hard
yeah no shit like
you know like whatever you're doing i
think is working and never feels rushed
okay to me well that means a lot to me
i'm always like look at her taking her
time and like using her silence and
being really powerful
with her words that's what i said my god
it's just again i'll just trust you
i'll just trust you i think it's really
interesting how you know i think that we
i'm gonna name drop real quick uh you
know what i'm not a famous person once
told me
that because the person that it is is
gonna invalidate
what i'm gonna say it's actually a
really smart thing said by a really
annoying person
which is that you can't tell you
afterwards okay is that you
freeze at the time you become successful
like you freeze like your habits your
thoughts about yourself
like your hair style your outlook you're
like this subconsciously your brain is
like this
worked yes you know yes and you're
well that's a lot of people peak in high
school and then like dress like they're
in high school like whenever you
peaked and felt like the first surge of
love yes yes
totally subconsciously your hippocampus
is like this is what works just keep
doing this thing i just interviewed
paris hilton
so it works surreal yes yes it works
keep it up and like that's and she she
still
does that but like i i watched her like
i was watching her documentary and she's
just following her life around i'm like
i relate to this so much because i
am stuck at like around 15
real hard are you stuck well it's not
when i became successful or anything but
like
i just feel like i'm still you know what
i'm holding on to
so much is before
i mean really before i had an eating
disorder i feel like life was so free
and like that was before depression yeah
before and
i don't know if it was eating disorder
before puberty i am holding on to being
like not a kid but a pre-teen because i
was later than all my friends that like
i didn't get my period until i was like
16. so that's just time before that you
know what i no worries
i didn't care about boys didn't care
about my body i didn't care about
like i would eat or i wouldn't it like
didn't the male attention
thing yes is fucking exhausting
and it's interesting because i was
thinking about you coming on today and i
was like you know naturally we're going
to talk about relationships
i'm sure that's going to come up we both
do that you're so um
uh sort of just unbridled in that area
and and i'm a little more um
trepidatious when i talk about it yeah i
feel
what i mean there's so many things i
want to know
i think that's i think that's good
mm-hmm to be to
hold something back to be a little bit
private about
something i'm not super private about
like when i'm dating so i think for me
i'm like because i've also
i'm openly identify as a love addict
like i've been in programs like i've
taken years off from dating
i took you know 12 months off from
dating and sex it changed my life
i just did that but not on purpose yeah
like not intentionally
i'm at 13 months now but not
god i should have started going to a
program before that i would have like
some actual
yeah uh ig live speed dating couch yeah
yeah i mean that is if you want to go on
a date with nikki you can do that on her
ig live yeah
um but uh no but i haven't been intimate
with anyone like right
like i haven't had sex in 13 months i
do find that i
and this is gonna sound weird and i have
this um uh
very cellular fear of not being
relatable
it's a very cellular fear of being
misunderstood
yeah i have a very deep fear of being
embarrassed uh
so i i'm trepidatious about saying this
my gosh
what i mean you don't seem like someone
who's scared to be embarrassed not
because
you because you're just you're just so
like
you just put it all out there i feel
like i watch you and i'm like
oh my god she looks so good being just
herself oh my
very controlled curated instagram i
know that's what i'm understanding right
now that it is
like 20 seconds a day we'll see chaos
that like
the times where you're like i'm a mess
like
we did kick some things out of frame
that would indicate
that they wiped the tears away yes yes
you keep
instagramming yeah okay so okay what are
you gonna say
i was literally just gonna say like i
you know like i was like okay i'm gonna
ask her if she's dating someone what's
going on in quarantine she's gonna ask
me if i'm dating someone i was like you
know what i'm at the point
where i really am not seeking being in a
relationship because
i am so fucking sick
of thinking about guys and if i'm not
anti-men
i fucking love men some of my best
friends are men i live with two men that
i'm not even sleeping with
the kids i want to be around men all the
fucking time you know um
uh you know but i'm sick
of real estate in my head being like
what about this what about this and
stuck in your stomach and did he text
back like i'm just
i have lost it'll make me cry if i
really think about it the amount of time
i have fucking
lost trying to get the approval of men i
mean even just in the grocery store the
other day i was wearing a fucking mask
and this guy went by and my
my um shoulders instinctively went up
and i'm like i'm in a mask
like this is fucking crazy so hardwired
and i grew up with a mom who it was you
know
all about men and all about your
appearance and all about your hair being
perfect in your makeup being perfect in
your push-up bra and like
the spanx and the fucking pantyhose with
the shorts built in that so
it was i need to lose five pounds that
was all i saw growing up was just you
live your life for male attention
and i just need a break yes
i mean the amount of time like when you
say that
even the amount of time i've had to
listen to my friends talking about
worthless guys and like
diddy texts like the worthless
conversations where we could have been
getting to know each other and talking
about something
that we learned that day or a book where
we
like just um and
just dealing with like the texting and
the guys and the second guessing
everything
i really don't do it at much anymore i i
like getting older because i'm just like
this guy's a joke i don't i can i do i
can do better
i deserve better not fair to them either
no they don't want us talking about them
all day
no they don't want us spending all that
fucking energy on them it sets them up
for resentments and right because
codependency resentments that they don't
deserve they don't want us fucking
sitting around
overthinking everything they do we talk
about them so much more than they think
because i don't know about you but my
male friends have are like when they
hang out with me my girlfriends are like
you guys talk about boys guys so it's
like sport yeah it's our sports
it's it made me so sad i mean right
before
all the shutdown happened i was getting
the point with a couple friends where i
was just like i can't do it anymore
because it's just talking about how to
look hotter
every every conversation is about our
looks and what we're doing with our skin
diet and i was just like i was having to
like
kind of question some of my friendships
like i don't
i almost i i actually did make a rule
with several of my friends that like
we don't say you look cute or you lit
your skin looks good or whatever
yeah no more compliments physical
compliments interesting i don't want
them because when i don't get them
then i'm like oh no what's going on so i
took
it out i went for about a year with my
best friend and she was very a huge
compliment
no compliments and it was so great
because some days i would be like she
hasn't said anything and then i go oh
she's not allowed to okay good i look
great
that's such an interesting experiment
because it's also
for her i would imagine you know i grew
up in an environment with a lot of
sensitive women women just
in general scare me i feel like i'm
always hurting their feelings i feel
like i'm always going to disappoint them
i feel like they're always going to get
mad at me
and i walk on eggshells around women and
i think that i'm going to make them
cry if i need something i think that my
needs are exhausting to them
i assume everyone is a malignant
narcissist who needs a bunch of
compliments
and i know that when i meet a woman and
instantly start
being unctuous and complimenting there's
something else i'm recreating my
childhood circumstances in some way
yeah it must be so interesting to i love
it like
i tried to do a 30 days no apologizing
oh how far do you think you don't have
to succeed at it just
it just shows you oh i and then i was
doing you have to do 10 push-ups every
time you apologize
and i was like it was so strong
because i just realized that i just am
in a constant my default is just apology
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm asking
someone for something i'm so sorry i
texted you i'm sorry
like uh and then as soon as i as soon as
i texted i was like why am i saying
sorry like
yes i was like i'm sorry i'm running
late or whatever it was but like
it was just unnecessary it was just the
it was almost the predictive text of
when i open it up it's like
i don't even have to type an i it just
like already knows that's what i'm going
to write
to another woman it just knows
i'm so sorry whitney like a million
things that
i haven't even done yet i feel like we
just handled that in a very adult way
yes i feel like we were just very clear
with each other
you said patronize each other you were
great because you go do we both want to
do this
or do are we being codependent and i i
like
that i was like oh my god let me really
think about this right now like do i
want to do it
what an emotive but i was like yes i'll
i know i'll have the energy for it
i haven't done so many things like if
this were another like uh if
this were just like my normal life
probably i wouldn't do two in a day
because i do
stuff every day but i've worked in four
months like yeah yeah let's
there we go because i also think it's
like looking at our motives am i doing
this because i'm afraid this person's
not gonna like me am i gonna do this
because i feel
pressure am i gonna do this because i
feel obligation and last night i went
into this eye this little pit my stomach
was like are you putting
are you obligating are you throwing a
pressure at her like are you guilting
her
not at all you were the gentlest but
asking someone to do something it like
brings up so much like doing a podcast
the hardest thing about you did
the hardest thing about doing a podcast
for me is asking people to be on it
because it's like
we became comics cause like i don't need
fucking anybody i don't need to ever ask
anyone for help it's just
i'm on my own i completely agree i
almost when you said that was like what
come on everyone wants to do this but
people have said that to me like because
i say the same thing i'm like i don't
want to ask them to be on my podcast i
don't want to ask them to be on my radio
show
i just thank them profusely today with
my guests i'm like thank you so much for
agreeing to this
it's like well they get to be they get
say yes or no you don't need to like
act like being here is just so hard to
not
act as if your presence isn't enough for
the other person or it's patronizing to
assume that they would do something that
they didn't want to do i
know you're diagnosing them with
codependents yes they're like no i said
yes because i would say no if i didn't
want to
yeah i'm an adult but but we don't do
that so we don't think that anyone else
has the capability of doing that but we
are
as sick as me yes yes okay really quick
because i'm just thinking about if
if i was watching this what i would want
to know based on what you just reveal
and it's just what i want to know
how do you see yourself like what do you
see
or like can we get into like what are
your insecurities
is that like too much no i'm fascinated
because
i don't know what you would come up with
like i could tell you my character
defect okay
i get into like a couple just give me
something
i love it i love learning people who i
project so much perfection
i've invited you here today but i think
people need those people watching i mean
i know people who are fans of yours know
your imperfections and you put that out
there but like
sometimes you i mean i project a lot
onto you and i just want to know
so interesting what is i want to know
okay and before and then before i just
want to make sure we don't forget
because i do want you to talk through
your process of doing kimmel
because when i was peeing you were
telling it to me and it was super
interesting and i think
most people think all of us are super
confident all the time you know
um and together my insecurities you know
aging is a big one for me
i did freeze my eggs when i was 33 and
that
i felt a tangible
exhale i felt a tangible um
sort of addition of space in my lungs i
didn't realize how much fear i was
carrying around
about uh basically not being able to
have kids or
not knowing i i still am like i think
i'm gonna have kids like i feel like i
know i'm going to but
you know um biology sexist and
by some weird little miracle i had the
uh sort of sort of tenacious um
kind of pull to freeze my eggs when i
was 33
and i kind of only i did it in a sort of
mercenary way
i was sort of like at least i'll get
some jokes out of it uh yeah yeah yeah
this is why any comedian does anything
yeah that's a big procedure with a lot
of
like so they were like this is going to
take four months and i was like
if i get some jokes out of it yeah like
everyone's getting baby jokes i don't
have baby jokes i'll have egg freezing
anything traumatized or anything like
you do like that as long as you can talk
about like i just go good
i'll optimize this into something else
that's the only thing that motivates me
oftentimes to do to do anything frankly
to leave the house frankly yeah
trying to go on dates to talk to
strangers because i need to get some
kind of fodder
right so um i did that i i am
you know my dysmorphia my body
dysmorphia that shit
is really um intense my fear around it
actually
is that i'm gonna continue to waste time
thinking about what i eat or my body i
read um
the tools uh phil stutz's book yes some
of it is like
kind of not as advanced as the people
listening to this podcast and you but
there is that deathbed exercise where
you envision yourself i only read the
first tool and then i was like oh i get
it i'm good
that's what i do with everything i think
it was a reversal of desire and it was
fair it was
running into fear it really helped me
edit my special because i was so scared
to look at myself i was editing my
special i couldn't get it done in
netflix was like
um we're just gonna do it ourselves i
guess you wouldn't look at the cut
i wouldn't i couldn't look at the
footage i couldn't look at myself i just
it was paralyzed and then i read that
chapter about like going to the fear and
like
fear sets me free i love fear and i was
just walking down the street like
i love fear fear set me free and i like
and then i went home and i fucking got
it done it really helped
so yeah that's an amazing one and
because fear um
if you say out loud that you're scared
the fear dissipates instantly
it's the amygdala stops producing
cortisol which is part of i mean i had
to like start where i couldn't even work
this through with therapists and stuff i
had to go to horses i had to go to
like animals that did totally non-verbal
because humans are already so triggering
to me and my instinct is to manipulate
them
and impress them and lie to them so i
couldn't even
therapist i would just manipulate that i
had a therapist who looked like a horse
and she
i was like she was terrible but that was
soothing about her
and now that i think about it but yeah
am i triggering you with my
poor sweater no
i'm yeah but that's a you so you horses
really did help you
horses oh game changer because horses
because they're prey animals they
respond basically
to um your energy and any kind of
desperation
results-oriented thinking needing
something from them
they interpret all that as fear because
they don't know instagram or
trophies or specials or agents or
managers they don't care about any of
that shit
so when you approach a horse and you
need something from them i need it to
like me i need it to be able to let me
pet it i need it to be able to let me
take a selfie they interpret all that is
fear
they get disgusted by it and they just
move away from you because they're prey
animals fear means there's a mountain
lion close by
this person's not a leader this person
isn't in charge you're not my lead mayor
and they move away from you
so it's a great way because you can say
everything's fine when you're terrified
we can lie right horses
you can't lie to horses yeah so it's the
only way that i was able to dismantle
and be honest with myself about my fears
but
part of the reason 12 step programs work
so well is you go in a room and you say
i'm scared
i'm insecure i want to do this awful
thing in front of a bunch of people and
as soon as you say it out loud
it's amazing it dissipates oh my god
right but our instinct when we have fear
is to
be quiet and shut it down but actually
saying it out loud
and i mean 12-step stuff and going to
those kind of things and just talking so
openly
do you ever in your experience in those
because i have felt like
oh this is like i've been doing this
with stand-up like this was
i was trying to do this all along like
share
what's going on in here like and i just
had no place to do it and no one would
listen
so i just created my own 12-step meeting
with no
rules or guidelines but like now i
i'm able to like channel that in that
place that's what i was trying to do all
along was just like give a share
never thought about it that way because
it's i'm not funny when i talk in those
things
and i but it it it just works i
i just want people to know that that
stuff's out there because god damn it
it's good it's it's such a miracle it's
free medicine you know but that's so
interesting you said that and also i
remember when i first went into program
to 12-step meetings my instinct was to
make jokes i would spend the whole
meeting
writing my share in my head oh yeah like
because i'd want to kill in the meeting
and then if you try to be funny in a
coda meeting or an allen meeting
everyone's just like
oh she's new
hey benton yeah is there something
interfering with your happiness or is
preventing you from achieving your goals
i can't say it and remain on the show
i'm kidding no i'm very happy but i know
some people are a real snap
well yeah and i was just talking to
about this with nikki glazer
um on this podcast just about how
crucial it is to talk to somebody even
if it's
you know like even if you can't leave
your house and go to an actual therapist
just the act of talking
to someone the way it releases shame and
the way you know to get feedback
from someone else is just crucial right
now yeah saying it out loud is always
healing but it's nice to say it to an
actual pro
don't say it to your friends that are a
mess you know my rule i don't take
advice about relationships from single
people i also don't talk to
people that aren't licensed therapists
about my problems but i also don't leave
my house
but thank god for better health
better help is licensed therapy online
you can start communicating in
under 48 hours the worst is when you're
going through something rough
and by the time you book a therapist
it's two weeks later and you're like i'm
not even i don't even remember what i
was upset about
i needed to talk to someone then yeah
but you waited too long you balled it up
and now you're look at you now
now look at you now you're a mess you're
gonna get timely
and thoughtful responses plus you can
schedule weekly video or phone sessions
so you won't ever have to sit in them on
one of those uncomfortable waiting rooms
you know where you got the little zen
garden with the sand
and the yogurt you can sit on your couch
eating nuggets
getting getting therapy yeah getting
better getting thick and getting therapy
it's more affordable than traditional
offline counseling
because you're not paying for some
therapist freaking lease right
yeah financial aid is available better
help wants you to start living a happier
life
today when today no good
today it's a brutal time out there
everybody is struggling
don't be too proud it's okay ask for
help better help
visit their website and read their
testimonials that are posted daily
visit betterhelp.com whitney betterhelp
help h-e-l-p
join the over 1 million people taking
charge of their mental health with the
help
of an experienced professional in fact
so many people have been using better
health that they're recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
huh crazy time special offer for good
for you listeners
get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
whitney now
i don't know if you guys have noticed
but i have giant teeth
and they fit your head good they fit my
head good yeah
thank you thank you so much um
and it's hard to keep my teeth clean
because it's just a lot of surface area
frankly to cover
i started using an electric toothbrush
like five years ago and then i started
getting annoyed the electric toothbrush
because you always had to like i kept
losing the top i didn't know how to
charge it
but there's a new one called quip
i'm holding it for those of you
listening listen to that
can you hear it oh you probably can't
even hear it it's so quiet how quiet it
is
you brush your teeth at night can you
hear that
it's me brushing my teeth with a quip oh
you can hear that yeah
yeah they just make it easy because they
deliver all of the oral care essentials
you need to brush
and floss better you know i would like
text you like two in the morning i'll be
like i need an electric toothbrush top
and then it takes two months to come and
then you have five cavities
the quip electric tree which literally
happened to you it looked no truly
it that didn't it didn't oh my god i
thought you were exaggerating and then i
realized that yeah right at the peak
pandemic
had a cavity oh my gosh in the pandemic
quip electronic toothbrush has timed
sonic vibrations with 30 second pulses
to guide a dentist recommended two
minute routine
and there's even a size down version
designed for kids
so basically every 30 seconds you move
so that you don't cause my thing is the
reason i got a cavity is i just brush
like my front teeth
the back ones i won't do as long like i
actually need yeah that times you so it
tells you you're good on this spot you
move now move forward you know what i
mean because i'll start getting sloppy
towards the back yeah also super easy to
travel with and very chic
i know it's very chic it's so it's like
it's like a very
futuristic um sexy
can i say that it looks too cool for me
i know
i don't own anything as cool as the quip
toothbrush and didn't you say that it
can stick on them
yeah so the little back piece peels off
you can stick it to a wall or a mirror
so if you brush your teeth
in the shower like me like monsters okay
what kind of monster brushes their teeth
in the shop someone has somewhere to be
[Music]
that's the saddest thing what kind of
narcissist needs to watch themselves
brush their teeth so you're just
brushing your teeth naked
wet yeah such as the water yes i am
i guess i think the toothbrush washed
the rest of my body with it too how
about that
oh quit brush the toothbrush the floss
the quit brush head
they're automatically delivered on a
dentist recommended schedule
every three months for just five dollars
each this is genius
a friendly reminder of when it's time to
refresh and stay committed to your oral
health
see i will brush my teeth down to the
bone if i didn't use quip
because they sent it to you and you're
like oh i need to change it yeah you
know it's time and
also the shipping is free three million
happy customers that
uh join them practice good oral care uh
easily and affordably with quip starting
at 25
especially since you're probably wearing
a mask and you finally had to smell your
own breath
if you go to get quip dot com slash
whitney right now you'll get your first
refill
free that's your first refill free at
get
q-u-i-p dot com slash whitney spelled
get q-u-i-p-dot-com
whitney when you get your quip tag me so
i can see you and your sexy quip
quip the good habits company what a team
oh yeah it's just it's it's awkward when
my instinct goes that way and i've had
that in therapy too where i want my
therapist to think i'm funny or like uh
you know
it's just such a coping mechanism i
remember once i said to my
uh therapist you know i'm always like
i'm an idiot and i'm stupid and she
she's always like why do you talk about
yourself that way you know
she's always saying you the way you talk
about yourself if someone else spoke to
you that way like you would call the
police
you know and like your self-talk your
your inner monologue your inner critic
and one time i was like oh god i'm such
an idiot i shouldn't have texted him
back and then
she was like why do you do that and i
was like oh no
i'm a comedian we like self-deprecate
like it's funny and she went
not that funny oh boy
oh no like you're mommy dary you
like you can tell me it's like wrong to
do but don't tell me it's not funny like
that
sucks but it's not it's not funny
self-deprecation is not funny it's not
endearing it's not charming it actually
puts pressure on the other person
to then like compliment you or take care
of you
oh oh my god it feels like pressure
it's ookie i wrote this thing for kimmel
where like
i am i'm speed dating on this thing i'm
meeting different guys and then at the
end
mark paul gosselaar like my my childhood
crush comes on
and i wrote the sketch that he he thinks
it's a make-a-wish and i'm like we're on
a date
and so he's like oh my god hi good to
see you
and i wrote up this whole thing that
didn't make it but it's like him being
like
oh i was under the impression like i was
granting a wish for like a sick woman
and i'm like
okay that's he's like that's what the
producer said and i was like what else
did they say and they're like
oh she's like she lives in an old folks
home and i'm like well i live with my
folks and they're old but it's like not
an old folks home and he's like
oh yeah her situation's hopeless she's
probably gonna die alone
and i wrote all these things and then we
did it and i felt
so fucking depressed afterwards even
though i wrote it i was control
i was in control of this whole narrative
that i'm unlovable i'm gonna die alone
mark paul gosselaar would never even you
know nothing like
someone like that would never even think
of dating me like that's the what
the story i have in my head and then i'm
like and all the writers like feel the
same way because they
thought it was funny and signed on to it
i'm like they didn't write that you did
you did and i was like i i gotta start
looking at
the stuff that i say about myself and
stand up and
change that because it's just it's
hurting me
and i don't know what you know bullying
myself
my comedy i like i'm cyber bullying
myself sometimes because then but then
when other people talk about
us like that these fucking comments
these trolls it's like none of this is
as mean as what you said to yourself
this morning in the mirror try to beat
them to it or like online
you try to beat them to it because you
know people are like
the other day i post a picture and my
hand was veining so i was like i know my
hands are super big
and people are like why are you posting
their hands veining i'm like because i
don't want guys to be like
you're right like you know there there
will be someone that points out but i
get ahead of things that no one would
even see
but why do you care and it's selfish why
am i roasting myself
looking that much like yeah no one cares
about you no one's looking that hard
no guy ever was about to fuck him was
like uh veiny hands
never mind well it makes them feel bad
about it they're like oh that looks like
another vagina and there's more vaginas
this is great this does like have the
same
kind of vibe but i do you know uh
remember someone said uh
to me that um comedy some like famous
comedian that i'm plagiarizing and if
you guys know who it is tell me
uh who said that comedy is we get we do
stand up to control
how we're embarrassed so it's our idea
right
embarrassment is our biggest fear and
we're just going to control
how you make fun of us yeah you know
like i'm in charge
what about roasts though like that that
you're in control and then you're
fucking up there you're like
oh boy yeah no i'm not and
talk about people saying things about
like rose have devastated me i've talked
about it before but like they say things
about me that i'm like i've
only i haven't even put it out there
because i wouldn't want someone to like
latch onto it and be able to
call back to it because it's something
i'm so insecure about like
looking like a man or look at like um
just being ugly and like having a decent
body but an ugly face like these
deep fears i have for myself have been
like expressed
from celebrities on rose and i know
they're writers in the room that really
have to concentrate and really have to
find something
which is by the way i'm i'm not going to
deny your reality i hear you
i see you having written on the roasts
i know i would always say the biggest
compliment to a woman is when they go
after your appearance because they can't
go after your career
yeah they can't go out they can't say
you're not funny that's a good point
okay all you have to go i remember being
in those rooms
and it was like fuck i mean it was like
sarah silverman or something
yeah i remember i think it was the
franco rose she was like you know i
think she talked about it maybe on
kumail's podcast or something they
called her old
yeah when she looks younger frankly than
all of us
but she you know you can't say she's not
funny you can't say she's not successful
you can't say she's not talented you're
like
fuck i guess we say she's oh she's 40.
she was like 40 or something
no you're so right it's a lack of other
things
to say but it it it
was like oh no they see it and like
did you get triggered by anything that
was said about you and rose i was so
i feel like unconscious at the time
i thought you blacked out i also
you know this is a blessing and a curse
and i am trying to figure out what part
of these maladap
adaptive behaviors and weapons you know
right
we talked about in this podcast like the
first thing i heard when i went to alan
on
is someone said i have good news and bad
news uh the good news is the war is over
and the bad news is you lost so the war
is over you lost we have all these sort
of weapons we're still fighting this war
that's been over for years right so
i remember like you know uh going into
the rose and being incredibly numb
i was in writer's rooms for a long time
like like i don't mean to play the like
being a woman in comedy is hard
thing but like in 15 16 years ago being
in a writer's room the only woman in
writer's room it was like
dicks in your i mean it was dicks and
your face was on a bill
fucking not billboard i wish on a dart
board and they're throwing
i did yeah uh throwing darts at your
face and they're calling you a whore and
a cunt and you're not funny i think i
just like
realized very early like you need to go
numb
like you can't feel anything you can't
see anything like
like being in the comedy store those
early days like i just went full
teflon and like just full now like just
i didn't let
anything in so that was probably
problematic but uh
i i really just like
turned it all off yeah and then i would
like randomly like
eat cake in my car and cry i'm sure that
was had something to do with it
you know you turned me on to froyo back
in the i did
you introduced me to one of those like
yeah
i think with the rose thing i start to
answer your question i think and we've
talked about this before in the podcast
is that like
i'm now at a point where insults can't
really hurt me unless i agree with them
so and i now know that when we for the
roast aside because that is a very weird
job it's a very odd it's almost like a
sport where you go out on a field
for people to fucking tackle you you
know it's like football you're like
someone wants to hurt me
some we are doing a job where someone is
trying to humiliate me
yes yes i'm signing myself up for that
which is why i had to stop doing it for
a while because i was just like i'm
training people
how to treat me i'm reaffirming a lot of
things i already think about myself
i would go out in public and people like
hey whore i know people think you
and i was like it's like tuesday at noon
at the airport and i was just like oh of
course you think you can talk to me like
that yeah because you've only seen me
laugh that off yes and it started
corroding at my self-worth
and you know um but i i am kind of at a
place where
i really do understand that when someone
criticizes you
it's they're just hurting and it's
anesthetizing for them yeah that's what
i do when i'm like
they're not that good i'm like oh do you
feel good about yourself do you need
that whitney
single i said i had a disclaimer the
other night when i was doing my speed
dating on instagram i was like
i'm not reading your comments i put a
little post-it note on the comments so i
could actually have a conversation
without reading people saying stuff
and i just was like i want to call you
out if you are going to say anything
critical let's all agree right now
that that per you think that about
yourself it's like so you
it almost like made people be like they
couldn't but because i just called it
out but that's so
anytime i remember the worst heckle i
could ever get is from like a hot girl
being like
ew like that's the worst thing in my
mind is like a hot girl thinking i'm too
gross to like be
friends with her like there's just
what's let's unpack that
i mean i just i don't know what it like
i just feel like
i put so much on i just feel like i'm
just innately like kind of
dirty and like kind of gross like it
comes it stems from low self-esteem like
i don't i have a messy room i've never
had a like in high school i didn't have
an organized locker my clothes were
always like
dirty like i just feel like i don't take
care of things i'm kind of like
you know depression like breeds like a
messiness that you become ashamed of and
but i'm not that person and i know that
but i
but that's my biggest fear of someone
just being like you're gross and i'm
like oh you're right i am gross i smell
i'm dirty whatever
and so i remember one time a girl just
going like ew
after a joke i did and um and the joke
was gross it was like about
it was gross and i was so mean to her
but i just felt so triggered but it was
about like
having anal sex and like having an
accident during it it was pretty a
visceral
yeah it was one of the first joke times
i was doing the joke so i was just like
you know when you just start go to over
the top and everyone's just like ugh
but her ew just really stood out to me
and i was like it's because it's
happened to you hasn't it
i was like you've pooped on someone like
a hundred percent she's pooped on sudden
she would not react that way if that she
had
and you could just tell she was like it
definitely had but like
that's the only time you have a reaction
that hard it's because it
it's something in you that you it's
happening and i love
that and i and i actually like you know
for me i have so much shame i get
triggered
sometimes um like i like when
i hear girls talking about sex and
enjoying it i realize that through
watching a lot of your work where i'm
like
oh my god was i enjoying it no i just
think times where you're like i like to
have sex i i think it was like on conan
where you're talking about like go have
someone go down on you it'll change your
life
i remember just being like oh my god i
don't even relate to this
can i just say that i'm so scared of sex
i am not the person that i was for these
specials i don't even
i haven't had sex in so long i've only
hooked up with two guys in a year
one time each and they were both like
very unsatisfying experiences
i'm so terrified of men and sex and i
watch
i think about the stuff i've talked
about and like i don't relate to any of
it i'm back at square one baby
so fascinating because i remember being
like i really want to talk to her about
how
i hate the word unapologetic even though
i know we talked about that but i hate
it when someone's like this girl's
unapologetic it's like
yeah it's like that just for 30 days i'm
trying it out
so like rare and like like um she's so
ambitious and unapologetic yeah like i
was thinking i was like
she really seems to enjoy sex and i i
know this is like a hot take but
i don't always enjoy sex and it's like a
thing where i feel like i know i have to
do it
a lot of it i realize is like oh i just
know i kind of have to do this
and it's not like amazing but sometimes
it is but
yeah i think i had an orgasm till i was
like 27. i didn't either
that's why i couldn't stop talking about
it when i finally did so i went on like
a roll when i was
having good sex in a really beginning of
a relationship that fueled
all of that material i mean like it was
like probably
a year of course like she just like
knows how to fuck like she
knows how to tell a man what to do no i
am
i like a guy a younger guy that i was
talking to recently was like you could
teach me a thing or two and i was
so stressed out by that i was like maybe
i could teach you like how to do a five
paragraph essay or like i
i don't have any skills in bed i'm
terrible at that i want everyone to know
that
i really am i want to lower the bar for
myself
so bad i take back everything i said i'm
down to do some stuff and try some stuff
i'm not even joking
the guy that i have taken a lover in
quarantine yeah you all know about this
you
met him on facetime for a second oh
remember oh my god yes that's still
going on okay
yes and i don't remember that he okay
yeah i told him i was interviewing you
and he was like oh my god nikki glazer
yeah i watched your special and he
thinks you're so funny and i was like
don't get any ideas like like don't get
any ideas about like fun sex
like i remember thinking like oh god
he's like so sorry to anyone i can't
blame being a female comic like oh he's
seen her
oh no i i think i've done a disservice
to women by acting like i have enjoyed
sex and like i did for a very brief time
i don't know if i ever will again or
really like
i hope i do but i really i think you
balance when
you just said i'm like when you just
said that like i don't really
like love sex whatever you said it was
like really i felt it in my core and i
don't think i've ever been able to like
hear someone say that of like uh i must
i'm not maybe i'm not that into it
but i i when i've had it i like it and i
like
like but i didn't come until i was like
26 years i had
one when i was 21 and then couldn't
didn't know how to masturbate until
much later even when i learned i
couldn't give myself an orgasm
i had to literally be like tied up in
four seven orgasms like that's why i
like watching bondage stuff because
girls are forced to have orgasms because
i will not let myself have
that much pleasure i have to have it
forced on me and i can get there now
because i've like worked towards it
because i'm like why are you like
holding back on this but i'm i've looked
into it i feel like almost
i'm like sexually anorexic like it's too
much i will and i will over indulge and
then i won't be able to stop and
so i'm just like i'm on a diet from that
and you know i have a book for you
okay it's called cupid's poisoned arrow
wait i know about this but didn't
getting to i do and then you said
cupid's poison arrow i talked about it
so much i only read a third of it and i
was like i'm never
jerking off again do you are you still
following
it i still i mean i do you do that like
huntrick like the
i don't know or whatever so i know some
people that do but this is basically
about you guys know i'm a big
neuroscience dork and the chemicals that
we emit when we have orgasms like really
do
make us high makes us atticty make us
crave make us crash make us obsessive
um if you don't have this
congratulations your enormi
our dopamine receptors like are really
not wired to just like have orgasms
every day
um it's like doing a whip-it it's like
the the the
you're getting high it's like it's it's
craving and then you're getting
obsessive and also
you know just the uh uh read the book
again uh uh cupid's poison arrow what
happens
after you have an orgasm is very
different in men and women men are wired
they produce prolactin i believe is how
it's pronounced
and they pass out we're wired to be like
thinking you're thinking wondering
wondering wondering planning planning
planning it just like
it amps me up i get very wired and then
i get very
addicty and when i start sleeping with
someone especially if the sex is good
i then when i spend time with them
afterwards i'm just like why aren't they
trying to fuck me
why aren't they it's just like this
constant like why don't we fucking
why don't we just have sex why aren't we
inside now when are we gonna have sex
and then i'm like
can i what bra am i wearing i need to
put a different bra like it's just like
i guess
it sparks this obsession that wasn't
there before the session
and it's honestly i turned so many of my
friends onto that book and a lot of them
who were having regular sex and coming
all the time i really couldn't even
apply to my life because i don't really
just
i just don't come a lot yeah yeah it's
not my first stress reliever thing to go
to
but my friends that applied it like saw
immediate results of like
my s i i didn't masturbate for like
you know two weeks and as soon as i did
three days later went on a shopping
vendor
all the things they talked about like
the depression that the obsessive
thoughts that come afterward
and then men when they come this was the
thing in the book that freaked me out
when they come they their body tells
them to go fuck something else
really soon because all the women in the
village that
are bro brains are wired to
like we're like cavemen we're all
ovulating at the same time
so he would fuck a girl fucking that
girl again
is a worthless thing you can't get
something pregnant twice yes so they're
literally repelled
by you after they come to go fuck
someone else in another teepee
i couldn't believe that but it makes so
much sense new pussy they want it
afterwards and they can't even help that
they want it we can't even blame them
that's what biologically they're wired
to want
and then that um basically how
ten months in that's when we right we
stop being as attractive because that
means the baby's born in the first year
like it's all it all makes a lot of
sense
math-wise and neurology-wise like how uh
men's dicks are shaped to s scoop out
the
cum of a complement another guy is so
crazy so do you like abstain
try to like i don't really i'm kind of
just at a place and maybe it's in like
my recovery and like i just i have so
uh much such a strong outreach game and
such a strong like
um i think uh self-control
is kind of my new addiction like i've
sort of you know it's all whack-a-mole
right
and to me the pride i feel when i don't
obsess about somebody
is is to me more orgasmic than anything
else like that's kind of my high now
right cooperation and productivity makes
dopamine so
those me living in those rigid lines is
is sort of
my high but you know i also have been
doing
almost five years of trying to change my
attachment strategy
of like my attachment style like this
you can change that i didn't get to that
part of that book it takes a really long
i just found out what mine was and i was
like
and then i put it down but it's
different with each different person so
um attachment strategy which i'm sure
you talked about on your show
yeah i mean we got into a little bit
yeah but you can be secure anxious
avoidant dismissive
and fearful avoidant but it also depends
on who you're with so if you're
with someone that's secure you're not
going to be as preoccupied or fearful
avoidant or
right so i finally am like seeing
somebody right now
that is secure which i've never met a
secure person and i don't
my goal in a relationship is when
they're protecting someone healthy
because you are
it's really like does it feel good um i
wouldn't
it's look we're in a pandemic we've
never been outside together
so this is a this is in a vacuum yes uh
he does not know me
uh at all so it that helps um
but i i do think
that my goal in a relationship this
might be a big one
is that when the person's not around i'm
not thinking about them yep i don't want
to miss anyone
i don't want to think about someone i
don't want to try to control someone's
behavior i don't want to wonder
i just want to be able to coexist
and be interdependent instead of
codependent and i don't know if it's me
or the other person at this point
you know or it's probably a mix of both
that's
i think the goal because my horse
therapist the one that
she really was she was not great to me
got a couple nuggets from her and one of
them was like the sign of a healthy
relationship is that
you could either you could live without
them very easily yes
yes like that's the best relationship
that you don't need them at all think
about every song we heard
growing up like i can't live without you
what would i i'm a mess without you i
mean we've been
you know i and trying to figure out
what's nature and what nurture we've
been conditioned to be
like romanticize really sick addiction
addictive love yes it's passion your
soul mates that's right
totally yeah you're right you're right
and we should
like that's crazy you tell that to
people who are in
codependent relationships and like you
should be able to live without them they
start going no i shouldn't that's not
right like they
freak out yeah because it's so foreign
to even think that way
yeah yeah for us and it's already tricky
because i do
think that i for so long not saying any
of this
is easy you're talking to like two old
gals here
who have read a lot of books which is
they're like
i also love to be needed it makes me
feel like the abandonment
risk is less this person needs me this
person can't live without me
uh i want to be able to live without
them i don't want them to be able to
live without me okay yeah that's the
thing that's going to be hard
that's what you got to watch you know
and so it's like the idea of just
literally like oh well they'll never
want to be with me because they want to
be with me because i'm not enough and
i'm not good enough but if i have their
insulin
you know like but if i know how to do
this special foot massage or you know
whatever thing
wow yes you know that's where it gets
like a little
dicey even just like dating though i
think is the
i think the beginning is the part i'm
most scared of i hate
strangers like i hate getting to know
someone new i
hate the very first date like that gives
me so much anxiety because i feel like
i just owe them so much on a first date
i just don't like
i i cannot handle the awkwardness of a
first date
i mean no one likes it that show dating
around on netflix that shows first dates
really helped me realize like
first dates suck it's not just me
they're all terrible and awkward but i
really can't do it interesting i
literally am paralyzed
i can do it's just like you haven't
heard any of my stories you don't know
my tricks
i don't know why that's the one that
freaks me out more than anything
that's so i mean it's you have a
magnifying glass on you i cannot do it
and
and i'm not in front of an audience like
i'm trying to like come up with like
dating shows because i'm like
if i'm gonna find love it's gonna be on
camera like i'm just more comfortable on
camera you're really good with this
which is um i always ask uh people on
the show red flags
things where you're like that's a bottom
line absolutely not
oh okay um there's so many
selfies too many selfies yeah and i i
hate to say that because that's not fair
because i do think it's okay for women
to have selfies
human nature is human nature and i very
openly talk about
if i see a guy trip and fall i'm out
like i it's just i'm sorry but i need
you to keep your balance i need you to
watch where you walk
i need you to be very i'm just i'm just
telling you that's going to happen and
it
it's not a choice oh my god the guy
you're dating if he's ever he knows he
knows stepping he knows very
carefully he knows all the time walk
very slow gingerly
when he does he'll just go look away
like it's happened to me like i've been
in love with someone saw them trip it on
a cobblestone
uh it was like oh it was truly over you
would have had a hard time finding love
back in
the 1800s people be tripping everywhere
like so funny not saying it's right but
just sure
you can't help it selfies i don't i've
like liked so many guys we're repelled
by people who are vain it's just
it's weird that's i don't like a guy
that's just like yuck bye dude no
and like knows they're hot because they
are hot i don't mind it when a girl
knows her hat cause i'm like yeah you're
fucking hot get it girl
yes and i know it's sexist and and it
shows to me that they care about look so
much and i can't be with someone who's
that caught up in looks i just can't do
it
as much as i want that approval from a
guy who only dates models and that's
oh my god my dream is today a guy that
like has a roster of like
the hottest chicks and then i'm all i
get to be added to this
list of hot women um that's something i
used to want and now i'm like
no because then i will be replaced by
another one i'm replaceable like
someone's talking to me about dating a
guy and like when you're against
their ti like you you should be you
should want to be
not their type because otherwise you're
replaceable by the way if someone has a
type it's
crazy that is so weird the idea that you
have a type like i just
um uh feel free to google this i'm about
to burn a bridge what's his name the guy
that
dennis quaid he just married a 27 year
old oh yeah yeah yeah who looks exactly
like
his current wife but like younger yeah
like they have the same old
yeah no like truly the same face like
how like lazy can you
like i don't have to like take the
photos out of the frames around the
house
like um but yeah having a type is just
creepy
anyway other red flags um just like
saying your dog is your best friend
on like these apps i'm just thinking
about the apps because like when i see a
guy that's just like
too many like i understand loving
animals i get it yeah like
just being like can't wait for you to
meet riley and it's just like
i can't i've heard dogs before yeah just
like always
like your dog is the most special like
don't you know that like that's not true
i also hate it when guys
name their dogs violent things it's
always like shooter
hunter cutter
stabber it's like why oh my god your
shotgun trigger it's like jesus
the cutest puppy ever it doesn't want
that name
school shooting yeah just like well
that's actually like a very weird name
suicide yeah uh that one is um
yeah the dog thing and then uh my thing
is having a dog
in your profile that's not your fucking
dog oh weird
i dm you and i'm like what's up with the
dog you're like that's my friend yes
it's like don't
whore out your face yes or like a
picture with their
niece and they like scratch out their
face or blur the face
that's always like this makes me feel
like you have abducted this child and
this is like a
picture from your trip to thailand that
no one really knows what you were doing
over there
like just don't put a picture of your
niece or just cut the child out
it's a red flag that you don't have more
photos to pick from frankly yes
guys need more photos and that is the
problem but any mention
be i don't i don't drink so and i don't
mind someone who drinks but if someone
is like
a beer snob or like their identity is
wrapped up in eating meat
or drinking i just that's that's such a
great one any kind of like
snobbery around like artisanal it's just
beer
you just like to get wrong that's right
that's right and that's okay that's
we'll work with it
yeah i can i can maybe do it but like if
you
if you've created i know that's the
problem
it's the be that it's white guys
dude can i just share a thing that
happened on the plane right here with
you
okay so i see at the i never meet a hot
guy
on the plane ever it happens to other
people it's never happened to me i'm at
my gate
flying here and there's a guy that sits
down next to me and i'm just like i
was like on a facetime with a friend i
was like hey i gotta go and i like took
out my earphones to be like uh
i'm able to be talked to you know send a
signal i laughed at something that the
the gate agent said because our flight
was delayed and she was being ridiculous
and he took that as a way of like hey um
i really i think you're great like he
recognized me which i was like shocked
by i was in st louis airport i'm like
wearing a mask and like
look gross i'm almost you know when you
get embarrassed when you get recognized
because you're like
i look like shit right now and you're
like i always look like this like you
recognize me without makeup on yeah
there's no point in wearing makeup yeah
yeah yes
right oh i look the same yeah basically
yeah so it was that
and i was like oh that was nice and i'm
i don't mind
if it's being into a guy that like is
maybe a fan
or something and also then they're
familiar with you or they they clearly
like comedy
i like comedy it's not a red flag if
someone's a fan of me okay yes okay
good so then we're talking about me
that's the red one
[Music]
that's hilarious so we board and he's
like
southwest so he's like hey um that's the
rest
oh he goes i'm before him on the thing
he goes save a seat for me we'll talk on
the plane
and we've already talked like 40 minutes
we get on the plane we talk for another
two and a half hours
straight and i don't like to be someone
who's chatting on a plane i felt bad it
was like kind of a late it was like a
8 p.m flight so people are sleeping and
we're just like
but i'm like you know i have to be open
i'm so tired i have to do kimmel
tomorrow but
i'm just like i want to be open yeah i
wanna i need to flirt this guy's nice
he's cute
and then two and a half hours into this
three and a half hour flight i finally
i'm like so how's dating been for you
during this
and he's like oh well you know i i date
and i'm like oh like what's
how's it he goes well i have a
girlfriend and i'm just like
are you joking me i don't how dare you
waste
my time and i felt so stupid because i'm
like
did i i thought this guy was into no no
well that is the trick of if you're
famous
is that a guys they're just talking to
someone they like and you think it's the
first time it's happening that you think
you're oh no that happened to me for
a little bit where you thought they were
into you and then you're like oh no they
wanted
to gay men that i thought
uh yes yes can you read the script and
yeah i thought we were like hanging out
and you were like asking me all these
questions and they're like can i get joe
rogan's number and i'm like oh
god yeah that's a tricky one it's it's
ha it's happened to me welcome
welcome to being a straight man i know
well it's that's happened with before
with like straight men in the business
that
they wanted to just like do a podcast
together yeah
instead of like date me and i thought
they wanted to like have sex this is the
first time it was like a normal guy that
i'm like
and it really it i just was
so mad if you have a girlfriend don't
talk to a hot girl on a plane for two
and a half fucking hours yeah how about
that
how about that also sir he's such a huge
fan so i guess
but he but like hit her patreon that
you got a private podcast you got a
private two and a half hour podcast i
was just like i would have slept on this
flight i was so
freaking angry and i wanted to be like
what
did you not think this was flirty
because i felt like i wanted to say
something but instead i just
talked to him the rest of the way
because i felt like bad that i like i
couldn't get mad at him now it was
but it was i was almost started crying
like i was
really upset because i was just like
what did i misunderstand am i so bad at
reading people and also am i
and and is he so hot that he would
almost scoff at the idea that i would
think he'd be into me like
what like
so unattractive that he wouldn't lie
yes and like did i not get him to want
to break up with her in this last two
and a half years like final answer
like still oh i know you had a
girlfriend at the beginning of the
flight but like you still
i'm not even joking you like but i was
being crazy before this
he did not deserve like he shouldn't
want to date me because
as we were talking he was mentioning
like and i'm thinking about you know
moving to uh
you know seattle for this and i was just
like well
why would he say that like he knows i
can't move to seattle we
are just sitting and talking for a half
hour and i'm already like
he said he doesn't want kids like why
would he say that and not even be just
open to them
like he just you have he doesn't know
where he's such a good mom just give me
a minute
it was so so i was already there's a
winning but here's what i'll say like
that is not
crazy that is we are wired that we are
literally
uh rotting from the inside we do have a
very finite amount of time not only
for this podcast because i have to let
you go because i don't want to be that
asshole who's going to be here forever
stop but i know i never want to stop
talking to you but i don't want to be
rude
but there is this sense of urgency all
the time if get out of my fucking
way if you're not the guy get out of my
way i have enough guy friends i have
i'm at capacity on that i don't need
more guy friends and i know i don't and
i certainly don't need to fucking talk
to you for two hours
i can be writing jokes i can be sleeping
i can be crying lots of things that can
be new it was back to what we were
talking about before with like obsessing
over guys
it this interaction where i was like you
know what nicki don't sleep on this
flight
open yourself up to this opportunity i
wasted it i didn't get rest i didn't
work on my jokes for kim like
i lost something because i was trying to
date
and that's why i hate dating it's a
fucking waste of time fucking romantic
comedies ruined us it's like i'm gonna
meet him on the plane like
no you're would you ever entertain
talking to a stranger on a fucking tube
of farts
i was living on that fucking movie did
you see
yeah this could work oh it's and i
i didn't even see the lower half of his
face so it could have been a really
like i had i'd never saw this i wouldn't
recognize him in public
so you're going to get a great joke out
of it or something yes somebody's going
to end up buying it
something that's what i said to myself
when it happened i was like at least
this is a story this is a thing i put
myself out there and that's what i got
that drives me nuts and i
always say to god do not waste a girl's
time like in relationships to anything
if you want to break up if you want to
cheat just
get like we'll hit we're fine we can
handle we'll be okay
yeah i just would have liked him to
mention it within the first half hour it
was
it was so it was the point where like i
felt like the people if you're a
girlfriend
it should come up in the first 10
minutes thank you thank you
that's where i was at maddox there were
plenty of opportunities i was definitely
even if it's not organic oh god usually
when i fly my girlfriend handles my
luggage thank you oh my god this will be
a 20-minute conversation
yep yep and i will tell you and i'll put
my headphones on and be like i need to
sleep and it would be done but
like how dare that's where i felt used
oh i was about to say the only thing
worse than being used for sex is just
being used for like airplane
chit chat that is annoying everywhere
and that's why the guy in front of me i
knew the guy in front of me was just
like these fucking people they will not
shut up
the whole ride and i was kind of
thinking like i bet they're listening to
like
us fall in love and it'll be like
they're gonna tell their friends and i
know when that guy heard
yeah i live with my girlfriend he was
just like oh i know
people heard it i had this thing one
time where i went on this and i'm
letting you go
is that um i and i have so many more
questions for you but
i went uh on this date with a guy
because for when i first started getting
on
dating apps i thought i was dating and
people would send me like resumes
and like stuff or it was like all like
people trying to like network with me
like work wise
at which thank you um i made it
and uh yeah and that is validated yeah
if someone star fucks you it means
you're a star just take the win
yeah so i went on a date with this guy
and
he was like halfway through was like
anyway so i'm really trying to get
started as like a stand-up or something
like that
and i was like i'm not gonna let this
i'm so
afraid of wasting time uh i feel like
i've lost so much time on bullshit
addictions and eating
shit and men and whatever that i was
like we're gonna make this work
give me the script like we are
developing this like i got him an agent
like i helped him out like
i like the idea that with that you get
off the plane with him and you're like i
just gave
up no we're we're dating we're going on
a date
we're not like this you're not gonna
have wasted two and a half hours we're
changing the end of this story well
that's why i got his number
and was like you know if you're like
this is a girlfriend like
i like that you like force him into
being in your life in some way like no
yeah i should have thought about that
that's why he didn't ask for my number i
go take my number because i was like
this has to if this i put in a lot of
work here
there has to be some chance that this
could be
this this we could still salvage this
we met on this airplane but he had a
girlfriend but we kept in time the story
is still
then i talked about it on a podcast he
saw that she got really mad because she
found out that he lives meant to be
anyway
so universe intervened and like now here
we are
and now he's just living in seattle with
him with no kids
and i don't really like the bottom of
his face but this
is i feel like we're not not in act
three
we're definitely i'm still building this
whole thing out yeah i have very big
plans for this okay so if you guys have
not watched kimmel
watch her on kimmel yeah brilliant i
have um a daily podcast that people can
listen to called you
up and uh which is so hypnotic
and soothing and it just feels like
maybe it's because i want to be friends
with you but it feels like just hanging
out with you
thank you it's so intimate it's so
intimate but it's like i was listening
to why i was like getting ready this
morning and i didn't feel yelled at
i didn't feel like you were like
throwing anger at me a lot of podcasts
are just like
like people are just yelling at you it's
their shit they're complaining
like i just felt like i was just hanging
out with you oh thanks girl and like it
was just like a really perfect blend of
just like intimacy
comedy authenticity like oh i didn't you
just gave me permission to feel this
thing i
wasn't feeling oh thanks so yeah i do
that every day and um
and who knows what's next and you have
this amazing ability to keep it to like
40 minutes which i don't
know it's a it's really oh yeah oh
really i saw one that was like 30
minutes i was like jesus
yeah that was a day where i just like
yeah it's it's hard
yeah yeah we had like planned to talk
for an hour i'm guessing we've been
talking for an hour now it's bad it's
bad it's your friend left and you're you
live your favorite
you live here now she'll be here you're
gonna be so mad at me after this
um and then uh you'll be touring soon
glazer.com
instagram go look at her veiny hands uh
on instagram
love you guys don't ride elephants
goodbye i always end these super awkward
oh i love that
foreign